what i have in front here is the brand
new refractor this is a decepticon that
you can see he comes in robot form and
if you look at the box itself
he
is
in robot form but if you look at the
background
he changes into a space gun but for
folks who are not familiar with this his
real mode is actually in a camera and
the issue is when it comes to your
product or the manual you realize that
all you do is you actually can bring him
to a space gun but there's no
instructions into changing him into a
actual camera so here's a quick guide
into how i'm going to change from
robot mode
into a
camera
so i have here refractor in his robot
mode so what do we do first take off the
button here looks like a shutter and
we're gonna turn his head around
like so
put them in
and then remove these back
what's important is the swivel here
and to ensure that his hand grips go
into these small little holes
and once that's done
just put them at the wrist if you can
see here
and just move them up
that's pretty much it
when it comes to the arms
and what we're going to do now we're
going to rotate the waist
so that his front
is now in the back
rotate the legs
and pull out these keys here
make sure the skis are on the outside
and what we're gonna do now
is put them in so to slot them in nicely
and if it's correct you should come up
like this
and we'll do the same on the other side
first moment here
oops
push this down
and if it's all correct
you should be able to tap everything
nicely in together
like so
there you have it
this is the easiest transformation to
change refractor into his camera mode
and
in order to do so we'll need to have
three of them
which is why we have these boxes here
okay
so from here
to here
here
now we're going to change these guys
from this mode into this
give us a moment and we get it
now that we have all three in order it's
time to assemble them
so the front is this
and these will be the back
if you look there are nice tabs to
actually go in and then this is how we
put them together
okay just like so
and
here do the same
and put them together
nice click
it's actually pretty sturdy so this is
how the camera looks like not quite that
yet
because
you do have
the camera lens
and the tripods
here
here and
yeah we are going to put the camera lens
together now
straight forward
just click them together
and there we have the camera lens gotta
make sure every
section is tight
and we're gonna figure out how to slot
it in
there we go
small little nubs there
to put it all in
click it in
and there we have the camera itself
does it look like a camera from the back
it's missing a shutter so we can put it
here
and you've got your camera
looking pretty good actually
so let's put it on the
tripod
put the tripod together
oops we're back there
it around
seeing this nice little knobs here so
actually once you put it together you
still need this additional part here
they're figured out
and you see the tabs go into these here
so once you put it in
let's get it it's very
put stable in here
okay
and you can actually put him into this
pot
and you're done
this is how refractor should look like
instead of its very
lame space garment
i think overall it's a very nice figure
and
i guess this is the most affordable
option when it comes to getting the
refractor series
compared to other third parties and
hasbro has really done a really good job
here
awesome